تعد روسيا واحدة من أكبر منتجي النفط والغاز الطبيعي في العالم ،
وتعتبر صادرات الطاقة شريان الحياة للاقتصاد الروسي
لدرجة أن جون ماكين قال ذات مرة
إن روسيا هي محطة وقود
تتنكر في شكل دولة
وبشبكتها الواسعة من خطوط الأنابيب التي
تربطها  يمكن للدول المجاورة لروسيا أن تمارس
تأثيرًا كبيرًا خارج
حدودها ،
اسمي نوح برينر ، أنا
مدير التحرير في نصف الكرة الشرقي لذكاء الطاقة ،
ونحن نغطي
جميع جوانب الطاقة وكذلك
سياسة الطاقة والجغرافيا السياسية
مناطق إنتاج النفط والغاز
التقليدية لروسيا هنا في الغرب  سيبيريا ثم
نرى مجموعة من وصلات خطوط الأنابيب
تتحرك عبر غرب روسيا إلى
شرق وسط أوروبا وفي النهاية إلى
أوروبا الغربية ، يمكن
لأحد خطوط الأنابيب نوردستروم 1 أن
يسلم 55 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز
إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي كل عام ، كان من
الممكن أن يضاعف nordstrom 2
كمية الغاز  أن روسيا كانت تنتقل
إلى ألمانيا الآن بالطبع مما جعل
الشركاء الغربيين ولا سيما الولايات
المتحدة  عصبي لأنهم رأوا أنه
يحبس دورًا في الطلب على
الغاز الروسي في ألمانيا ولكن أيضًا
لروسيا ضمن سياسة الطاقة
والمجال الجيوسياسي لأوروبا
ردًا على الغزو الروسي
لأوكرانيا نوردستروم 2 ،
لكن أوروبا لم تعد كذلك  يُعتقد أن السوق الوحيد
للطلب على النفط والطاقة الروسية في أوروبا
بلغ ذروته ، وبالتالي
فإن مستقبل روسيا ومستقبل تجارة الطاقة في روسيا
يتجه نحو آسيا ونحو الصين على
وجه الخصوص
في أقصى شرق روسيا.
حقول الغاز التي تم توصيلها بالصين
عبر خط أنابيب يسمى قوة
سيبيريا في عام 2019 ذكرت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
الصينية أنه بحلول عام 2024 ، سينقل خط الأنابيب
38 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز
كل عام
لدى روسيا مقترحات على الطاولة
لبناء خط ثانٍ يعرف باسم  قوة
سيبيريا 2
ولكن هذا التحالف بين روسيا
والصين يمكن اعتباره طريقة أخرى
تستطيع روسيا من خلالها الاستفادة من إمدادات النفط
والغاز على مستوى العالم لإنشاء
تأثير يتجاوز ما يمكن أن يكون ممكنًا
حيث لا توجد سيطرة قوة الطاقة هذه
على مثل هذه الإمدادات العملاقة للطاقة ،
جعلت بعض البلدان ، خاصة في
أوروبا ، تشعر بالقلق إزاء
نفوذ روسيا ، وتقول فكرة تسليح روسيا لإمدادات الغاز لديها
إن حجب إمدادات الغاز أو النفط
كان سؤالًا رئيسيًا
للكثيرين في  الغرب ولكن حتى الآن في التاريخ
لم نر روسيا تفعل هذا ،
وتزود روسيا 40 من الغاز في أوروبا
والبدائل إما
مصادر خضراء غير متطورة تقلل من
المحطات النووية أو الفحم المدمر للمناخ
مع عائدات الطاقة الحاسمة لروسيا ،
أي خسارة في المبيعات يمكن أن تكون ضارة  لكن
مع استمرار الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا
واستمرار العقوبات الغربية ،
كذلك فإن التهديد بقطع التصدير
للصراع في أوكرانيا أه مع
الغزو الروسي قد خلق
تحولات زلزالية في الطريقة التي تفكر بها أوروبا
في طاقتها حيث تحصل على
طاقتها من أوروبا  كان يعرف دائمًا
أنه يعتمد على الطاقة الروسية
وكان يُنظر إليه دائمًا على أنه مؤشر ضعيف  في
إطارها الجيوسياسي والأمني ، فإن هذ
الغزو والسرعة وا
قوة التي استخدمتها روسيا في أو
رانيا قد حفزت أوروبا حق
ا بطريقة للتعامل مع هذا الأمر بجدية أكبر مم
رأيناه من قبل.